good morning if you could uh join me as
in rise for the Pledge of Allegiance
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
Injustice For All
Welcome to our continuing series of
hearings on the bill
reform issue
yesterday we heard a lot of information
there's a lot to take in that we're
still going to be processing
today we're going to take up a little
bit less complicated or actually we'll
see the issue of paying bail
Commissioners and making sure that they
are compensated appropriately for their
time
equipment
and things of that nature
um
with that we heard from bail
Commissioners yesterday so I think we
have a pretty good idea we heard one
person was owed 50 something thousand
dollars
from the state in just over a period of
two years
um obviously that's unacceptable we ask
a lot of these folks
they're volunteers and we understand the
spirit of the volunteerism of New
Hampshire as all of us know we are also
volunteers but no one's asking us to
supply our own equipment our own paper
our own vehicles and mileage we get paid
for mileage it makes it seems ridiculous
that
some people who appear to be for the
most part retirees are expected to use
their small pay to
not only
support us
with their time but also their their
vehicles that you know the the gas
prices just keep going up
um it's just unconscionable in my mind
the way that they have been treated
especially in light of how important
they are to the system without them it
would it would literally come to a
screeching halt so I'll open the floor
for a discussion if anyone would like to
speak on the topic or has any ideas or
thoughts I'll let you guys have at it
first
representative roach thank you Mr
chairman so just coincidentally last
evening I happened to be talking with
the police chief in one of my towns and
he was telling me that in Cheshire
County uh the best of his knowledge
there is only one bill commissioner at
this point uh the other four are
permanently unavailable due to not being
not being paid um the forty dollars that
is required
so one you know one bail commissioner
for entire accounting I think is a is a
stretch his suggestion was putting it
somehow into the to the court fees
indeed um and my concern is even that I
think we need a timeline
um you know most people in this state
when you perform services or work you're
expected to be paid within two weeks of
that work performed especially when you
have your own Financial outlays to be
reimbursed so I think we need to look at
the amount we need to look at the time
they're paid and the source of the
funding
anyone else represents Stone thank you
Mr chair
perhaps it might be something to look
into if we would consider
billing per Bale and the state would
actually pay per bail and then they'd be
reimbursed by either similar to Cost
Containment but I know that we've
discussed the Cost Containment may not
be the proper entity for collection but
including the court fees that basically
the state would pay the bail
Commissioners per bail and then they the
state would recover the funds
I think that is a an excellent uh road
to start going down I believe that the
court has the ability to order someone
to pay whereas the bill commissioner
does not
so if the court pays the money up front
it's the Court's money to get back and I
feel like they'd be more motivated to
get their own money back than to get
money back for someone else so I think
that that's a good starting point as far
as in the bill that we draft
that we put in there that the bail
Commissioners will be paid by the court
per bail and I would suggest that we put
a a two-week time limit for that to be
processed
depending on when they're submitted
um and
then we order the court to collect it as
they see fit based on the indigency or
not of the the defendant that's their
determination to make if they feel like
they can get their money back or not
um we will of course have to put some
seed money
in that to give the course time to
request it in their budget going forward
so we'll have to discuss one
how much to ask for
and going forward how that how that
structure would look
representative Muse did you have
something I thought you'd see raising in
it's interesting after having sat
through these hearings uh on on bail
Commissioners for uh all three of all
three of my terms
um
one of the things that strikes me is
just how unusual the situation is with
Bill commissioner pay uh
it would be like asking policemen to
collect a fine from the people they
arrest
so and that that would be the way that
we actually pay police salaries
so I mean if you extrapolate the way
that we handle Bill commissioner pay uh
and you and you you sort of Transport
that over to roles that may be more
familiar to us I think most people would
pretty quickly come to the conclusion
that it really makes absolutely no sense
and that we do need a much better way if
we're if we're going to retain the bail
commissioner system we need a way of
making sure that people are paid for the
service that they render they're paid
consistently they're paid fairly
and even in a situation where people are
getting paid a hundred percent of the
time which which is not the situation
now
we are still saving an incredible amount
of money as a state by by having this
system and the longer that we let this
situation fester and it's been festering
for at least uh the the five years so
far that I've been in the legislature
the longer that we let this whole
situation Fester
we're going to have fewer and fewer
experience Bill Commissioners and at
some point the whole thing just starts
to crash and we really will have no
choice but to look at another system so
at this point we do have a choice and
and I think it does start with making
sure that these folks are paid fairly
inconsistently
I agree uh wholeheartedly representative
um Rhodes thank you Mr chair I just have
a follow-up to representative Stone's
um suggestion which would be
there are several bail Commissioners
right now that are out
thousands of dollars and you know when
we go forward with this initiative
whatever it is that we you know come up
with today or over the next several
weeks
I think something we need to address is
are we moving forward from here as in
you know it's still up to that bill
commissioner do what they need to do for
the for the pay that they're owed or are
we looking at somehow trying to make
right the wrongs that have been done
over the last
several years I think that's something
that obviously is going to be a
conversation so I think we need to be
proactive with how we're going to handle
it
um I think that um best case scenario we
we would
um include in whatever funding we
request an amount to reimburse
outstanding debts to the bail
commissioners
and have them start with a clean slate
if possible but right now when I think
I'm gonna need is um and perhaps
representative scitec can help
um
we need a kind of a number like in other
words does anyone know exactly how many
bail Commissioners we have
and then
about how many Bales I mean and because
we have no I T system it's kind of
impossible to come up with that number
but we have to come up with a number to
ask for to be able to pay the bill
commissioners
any input on that representative side
Tech
almost none I don't want to say things I
don't know because I I only know Salem
Pelham Windham and our Dynamic so we
have a pretty we're unusual in that
we're close geographically
so I don't spend a trip to one of these
places is basically takes five dollars
off of my bail not
because you really had to get there you
didn't walk
and we have a pretty very good uh High
rate of return I it two out of ten is
maybe it's one out of ten because we
also get checks appear
semi periodically from the court by the
way I might add
where is the court I've not maybe
they're watching but you'd think they'd
be here to have an ore in this water
okay so I I wish I could tell you more I
think my sense is
I'm speaking for me I don't know what Mr
Leary might want to say but going
forward correcting the situation I don't
think we're looking I don't think
anybody's looking for anything else but
get this straightened out
if I may because this I I don't want to
talk much but I do want to throw this in
because we're looking at the overall
bail situation
and the Roman censor Cato ended every
speech no matter what it was about with
carthago delenda est Carthage must be
destroyed and I want to end everything I
talk about with we need a training
program or I'm talking with Mr Leary
about how he handles it we handle it
District Court tells us something in
October another District Court tells us
something else these it's like a golf
course with local ground rules well wait
a minute this is a system of justice I
I'm not comfortable with that I
look when I'm a bail commissioner I
follow the rules I don't follow what how
I might vote in the house or what my
personal preference is I represent a
system and everybody is Mr they're every
one of them as far as I'm concerned
guilty who cares I represent a system
and they're treated I tell them I'll
I'll stop here uh you showed up you're
acting like a business we treat you like
a business may not be a business you
want to be in but please keep up the
good work
thank you for listening
thank you for your input
um sir would you like to maybe address
the issue of the number of bail
Commissioners uh how many are in your
area emergency
we have four in our area uh one is
semi-active three actives do you have
any concept or idea of how many the
state we have is it I I've heard from
people more involved by the way amazing
you know Trixie with fed that's about
here I'm on the condo board with a
relative of hers and through marriage I
was at a meeting last night I'm trying
to talk him into a bail commissioner
because they need one in either for her
I'm going to try to talk her back into
it or uh for the dairy Londonderry
Manchester area
um so I think Mr Leary can probably tell
you more than I can about that or I'm
kind of insular I know what I know but I
don't know more than I know gotcha sir
would you approach the mic
thank you Mr chairman again for the
record my name is Paul Leary I'm a bail
commissioner and pointed out of Franklin
Court
and I am the only one appointed out of
the Franklin Court however we have
several from the Laconia District Court
that cover as well as a couple out of
the Concord Court
pre-covered we had approximately 120
bail Commissioners it was what I was
told
posts covid the first round it was down
to 100 and currently from the scuttlebut
we're hearing it's about 85 now and
people are doing what's called The Quiet
retiring on either the Justice of the
Peace Commission expires or the bail
Commissioners expires they just don't
renew it and they just disappear and
sometimes people move and the Court's
not aware of that until if they have to
have an annual meeting and then we
happen to be talking oh no they went to
Florida two years ago so the thing is
that's why we're figuring about 85 and
that's still plus or minus
with regard to
um you've heard what we're talking about
trying to come up with a an amount to
seed this this program of making the
courts have to pay
um do you have any concept of how many
Bales are conducted per year and I know
it's see the court the court system will
be able to tell you that because they
record all of that stuff because they
have to but it's individual courts
there's no I'm sure the courts have
because they have the administrative
office of the courts I would hope in
this day and age that they've been
reporting monthly their activity to the
court so they'd have the totals where
did the checks come out of
the checks that you get where did they
come out of
I don't know they come in an envelope in
the state of New Hampshire right it's
like they don't they don't come very
often no I I'm just trying to I figure
someone I can call and say could you
tell me how many bills you've done last
year I said that ingested my last
training in Laconia which was the best
one in seven years and all of a sudden
in the next two weeks I got like eight
or nine checks from the court and then
it was crickets for a long time well
perhaps this will generate a few more
chats but here's the problem
again I told you yesterday will we fall
in the scope of things we understand
that but the bail commissioner's fee is
tagged on after everything goes to the
court so the very last payment that the
defendant makes whether it happened to
be six months a year five years or ten
years then we get our check yeah we need
to be at the front end yeah but I think
our representative over there was headed
in the correct direction but don't limit
it to them to every two weeks it's just
whatever the bail Commissioners put in
in a two-week period they report it for
the next period we get paid and that's
what I meant by that but from my and I'm
speaking just on my behalf not anyone
else
it would be ridiculous to think at this
point because some of us I've only been
doing it seven and a half years and I
showed you I'm at over fifty one
thousand
but since I typed that up I've done
about seven Bales and I've only been
paid for one out of the seven so that
number's going on it's like the deficit
clock that's yeah it's kind of like that
and if you want to make this happen in
reality we're trying to take care of
today and the future
unfortunately it's the past and when I
came on Judge Gordon told me I'd be paid
for three out of five
that's 60 I told you I've been
collecting 62 to 68 so what he told me
back in March of 2016 is held true so
the thing is I knew that when I came
into it what I like that
absolutely would my wife like it even
better absolutely but I considered it a
hobby in a way so the thing is that's
from my standpoint but let's fix it for
today and going forward then later on if
someone wins the lotto and gives it to
the state to pay off all the bail
Commissioners we'll gladly take it but
let's fix it for today and go forward to
the future well I like to aim high and
see where we end up oh absolutely
um so here's the problem and I hope the
com everyone's listening so even if I
were to be able to call and say okay so
how many bails did you pay for that
doesn't tell us how many bills were
actually done because they're not paying
for all the bills so
I'm trying to see if there's a way and
I'm going to representative SCI text
point I'm gonna have to call the court
and
see if there's a way for them to figure
out how many bales were done last year
in total well and I suspect they won't
be able to tell me
I think they may because say like the
electronic bench warrants I go and I do
one defendant like I told you the one I
had he had nine electronic bench
warrants there were seven different
courts but each one of those nine
because they were electronic bench
warrant required a bond
that what you need to know form two more
pages and the Circuit Court bail order
form so there were five pages for each
one so 45 pages of paperwork seven
envelopes seven stamps and if it went
over four pages you needed the fifth
stamp on that just to give you an idea
of cost time spent was about five maybe
six hours total time between going there
coming that and finishing up addressing
all the envelopes and then the cost that
doesn't count going to the post office
dropping them off going to the bank
making the deposits writing the checks
again we have to pay for our own checks
to write to the court too so yeah it's
it's a lot of cost involved but we're
only allowed to correct one bail
per call doesn't matter how much we have
to do or how long we're there
so if you get one call to one city and
there's six defendants to be billed you
would get be able to bill for all of
them correct that's a different story
matter of fact had that happened the
other night five
young gentleman out partying all under
the age of 21. so that was one of those
gold mines so yeah it doesn't happen
very often
they all had the money and it was like
that was a surprise too and it was one
of those Christmas came early 1 30 in
the morning so the thing is it does
happen and uh since taking starting to
take credit cards that helped a lot
especially doing the remote bailing
because I'll be honest I've got to go
over to Bradford I've got five envelopes
over there I got to pick up I've got
three in Whitefield I've got one down
somewhere in Rockingham County in the
middle of nowhere not easy to get to
it's been there for three years I'll get
there eventually but it's not that and
that's one of the biggest problems about
remote bailing but the worst part is if
it's a cash bail
that's like Plymouth won't hold the
money and dispatch even until the next
morning to come up and get it
then I just don't call
it's like I don't want to be driving at
night in really bad weather because I'm
reaching that age where Mike probably
shouldn't be and you got to understand
that and know it so it's like it's not
that I don't want to do it but it's like
hey guys you got to work with me halfway
you want me to do it I'll do it hang on
to the money and I'll come up but
they're worried about it
put it in a Gun Locker take the key out
yeah it seems we heard that yesterday
that bail money that isn't for the bail
commissioner's fee seems to be being
treated like a hot potato nobody wants
to hold it or take it well you can
understand in this day and age because
the thing is if it disappears who's
reliable forward or responsible for it
yeah I mean it's the same with the jails
like the jails we have to go out to
Merrimack County Jail the round trip is
16.6 miles it's doable in any kind of
weather except when the trees come down
across the road that just makes it a
little difficult okay so okay thank you
any anyone have a question uh
representative Stone
I'm not sure if you have the information
on this or not but one of the things
we're seeing in a lot of other avenues
is the lack of Volunteers in certain age
groups do we have any Bill commissions
that you're aware of that are actually
under the age of 50.
so the best of my knowledge and belief
at this juncture or time I would say in
the negative but I don't know for sure
thank you was that evasive enough that
that is is enough to say that probably
not
um so again though but
the nature of this job is difficult for
someone who has a full-time job and the
family or you know pets it's just it's
it would be very difficult so I can
understand the the age group but at the
same time that that's incenses me more
that we're taking advantage of them so
um Mr chair yes I could just inject on
that uh when I first came on there was a
young lady she was probably in her 40s
who trained me
and she was happy I came on she says you
can take care of the evening and the
nights I'll take care of the days
because of where her job fell that
worked out well
so the thing is there are some people
out there that are willing to do you
know like School shift type things and
in this day and age
I'm sure the court system would be
willing to take someone if they had six
or eight hours a day that they could
give because the thing is the system is
stretched and I told you I bailed nine
counties the one County I don't have and
I'm not interested to jump into it the
Cheshire county for the reason the fact
is they only have one
yeah and that's kind of a hike
okay
um to your best to your knowledge or are
you representing scitec how long is the
the fee been forty dollars
since 2008 2008
that was in your report of 2019. okay
um
how does the committee feel about uh
increasing that to 50 I mean the 10
increase over what um that number of
years with the I know representative
scitex probably about to say no let's
just stay with the 40 but go ahead I'll
say that I'll say that but what we'd
prefer I think isn't an increase but I
think they would prefer because I'm
lucky I just to be paid it all by the
way Salem does shifts that's how we
handle it that's so one week is
destroyed you're you are 24 7 for one
week then you're offered uh I think we I
think they we would appreciate the
Assurance of the forty dollars not 50
Chancey as I said I I um I believe that
we can walk and chew gum at the same
time and I think that um it's it's a sad
State of Affairs that you have to settle
for something less than would be
appropriate just so that you have
something at all
um so I would like if the committee
agrees to try and shoot for fifty
dollars I mean we still have to
negotiate with the Senate and but I'd
like to start a little high so that if
we do end up back at the 40 at least we
haven't lost ground
representative Stone
thank you I would support the 50 I think
that'd be a much easier Revenue source
to go with than to deal with mileage
where if you included mileage it'd be a
more problematic and more comprehensive
staff time and document time and
Reporting time I think a straight 50
would be keeping it very clean and
should be a little more palatable for
the other entities that are involved in
this I I was thinking the same way
because mileage I think that they should
get mileage but to your point that
requires Court staff processing and so
every everything we do is throwing a
pebble in a pond and the ripples go out
represent scitec
um I have I have customers from both
jurisdictions from Massachusetts and
from
New Hampshire so I've done some
comparison shopping
you should be aware Massachusetts
charges 40. and so I you know I don't
know that we care about what they do but
that's a point of reference the other
thing is it's done by the clerk of court
yes in Massachusetts and many
I don't want to exaggerate I've heard
several times
my customers my clients my restees thank
me for the promptness by which we get
there we had to wait eight hours in
Massachusetts so yeah it's done by the
clerks and they have they do have bail
Commissioners
um but it the clerk of courts in the
local Town usually handles it and you do
have to wait for a bail commission if
the clerk does not want to get out of
bed so there's that and I don't believe
I'm not sure the clerk of courts is
salaried anyway quite handsomely in
Massachusetts I may have
um so I don't know if they get that 40
on top of that or if it goes to some
victim witness who knows sir yeah go
ahead representative means
you know one of the things that we've
also heard in in some of the other
sessions
um uh and this is from from the court
system was just the unusual status of
bail Commissioners
um they're not employees of the court
system they're not really contractors of
the court system
um they're volunteers who for the most
part are are inconsistently trained uh I
know a few years ago in the commission
that we had on bail commissioner pay one
of our recommendations was to try to
professionalize it a little bit by
making sure that bill Commissioners at
least got ID cards state ID cards and
one of the things that we heard
yesterday was somehow that got
translated into a computer printout with
a little tiny picture at the top that
these folks are supposed to drag along
in their wallets
so I mean part part of it is I I think
one of the things that that just always
strikes me about these hearings is how
critical the role is and and what a
critical role they play in the in in the
criminal justice system
but there just seems to have been a A
continuing refusal on the part of the
court system to really do much of
anything to professionalize the role
um and and I think these are people who
really regard themselves as being
professionals and they take care of you
know a lot of that kind of activity
themselves I think you know the vast
majority are very responsible people
but the but the fact that they're
essentially treated like the poor step
children of the judicial system
doesn't really serve the people of New
Hampshire or them
um very well given the kind of
sacrifices that they make to do the job
so you know the bottom line is if we're
going to have a system that depends on
folks like this
those folks need to be able to depend on
the system to at least make sure they
get paid they get properly trained and
that there are Professional Standards
that they can comply with and shoot to
aim for and I mean
I mean I don't see you know I was in
business for a long time I don't see how
you recruit anybody to a role where
they're inconsistently paid where
um you know
not only is it a situation where they
may or not get get paid there's a
certain amount of personal risk involved
and driving to these locations at night
through snowstorms and things things
like that when they get there they find
that the handbook uh that's supposed to
be their Bible hasn't been updated since
2019 and I think one of the things you
were saying is the the 2019 version
isn't accessible on the on the website
or the 2020 version
so I mean this is this is just really
inexcusable
um and uh it it's just something we need
to fix
agreed and and to the uh to I don't want
to you know just like I said yesterday I
I didn't want to bail Commissioners to
feel like they needed to be defensive I
would like to to extend the same thing
to the court
um I spoke to the new um uh liaison to
the legislature a week ago
um she's also the general counsel and
she's very open to all of this
um and right now I'm working on setting
up a meeting with the Chief Justice
who's open to the meeting so um I feel
like you know we have a a little bit of
a different court system we're dealing
with just like we're a different
legislature with the new chief justice
is kind of taken over and and wrapping
his arms around everything so this is
the perfect time I think so um we're I
believe we'll be able to address these
issues and the court we'll see hear them
with an open mind and what we want to do
and it's difficult for the court to be
here
because they have to stay out of policy
um it would be great if they were here
as a resource to give us information but
I feel like
um we're getting all we need directly
from The Source on this on this matter
and we'll bring that to the um to the
courts with our proposals I think what's
important what we need to do is
go to the court and say this is what
we're thinking is this workable and if
not why not and how much do you need sir
go ahead just to answer something that
representative news brought up is when
we came on we were told we were not
employees yes that we are independent
contractors and we receive a 1099 at the
end of the year we are officers of the
Court inferior but we are officers of
the Court Justice is justice of the
peace is and that's even further down
the line yes and that's one of the
benefits of having you because we don't
have to pay you benefits we don't have
to so that's that's the reason that the
1099 in the contractor that being said
there's no reason that we can't give our
contractors what they need to do the job
that we are Contracting them to do
okay so I think we have something to add
oh yes sir go ahead Mr prayer uh
representative you talked earlier about
swearing him in I don't think that would
go against anything not being part of
the system if we could swear them in and
also along with that a simple laminated
ID because they're going into police
stations and sensitive parts of the
buildings and courts and everything else
they ought to have a little
to buy his license type ID that they can
wear on their neck to show that they're
part of the system and not part of the
problem
agree let's take a just a quick informal
vote 50 is everyone okay for shooting
for fifty dollars
absolutely representative Reed thank you
thank you and they're putting in like
six hours they're getting like eight
dollars and can we do better then I
would rather not try to do better I I
agree
um but we have to look at what first of
all we're how much is the court going to
be able to get back first you know with
with a large percentage of the of the
defendants being indigent
the courts aren't going to be able to
get that money back so it's going to end
up being funded at a general fund every
year in a budget so we have to really be
careful with that I think if we could
get 50 we can come back later
um let's let's get a beachhead and once
we take the beach head we can advance so
I think 50 is a as you heard from
representative he's nervous that might
be a bridge too far
um but we're going to start with that
but your point is well taken so we we
have an informal agreement on shooting
for 50.
um to representative Pratt's point do we
have an agreement on directing the court
to make a uh to make a agreement enter
into an agreement with the DMV to
provide
um identification
I don't agree IDs
also do we have an agreement on doing
whatever we need to make sure that they
are sworn
such that they are able to access
FBI and criminal justice information
representative Stone
thank you Mr chair I my memory served me
correctly I think that's more of an
issue not being sworn but completing the
required training
to be certified now I think there's
probably a couple of things let's do we
agree that we need to do whatever we
need to do to ensure that they have
access to criminal justice information
yes does everyone agree to that
information
that would probably be one of the
justices if they had to be sworn of Mr
Sure yes sir correct me if I'm wrong but
it isn't all bail commissions have to be
Justice of the Peace yes so they're
they're assets yeah in other words we
fill out two applications one is a
Justice of the piece one to be a bail
commissioner we have to go get four
people to sign off that we're
Representatives we have the state police
background check so we're basically
twice in the five-year period of our
appointment we've been a background
check has been done because you have to
take a note of office of any kind yeah I
have to sign off especially as a Justice
of the Peace the bail commissioner is
more based on the fact to be
a bail commissioner you have to be a
Justice of the Peace so we're already
sworn okay okay but the thing is to
sieges this is where you have to be
careful this is this is the federal
government right and it has to do with
peace officers basically in other words
you're a police you're an executive
branch we're in the judicial branch
however in sieges
bail Commissioners are allowed to review
I can't possess they can't send me an
email or a fax or any of that because I
don't meet the criteria but because of
the job functionality I do I'm allowed
to review it
okay we're gonna we're gonna look into
that and see if there's I know
probations allowed to see and hold and
have but this one and they have I
believe the power of arrest because they
can take people into into custody it is
a good point
um okay so for the committee I'm looking
to seeing what what level if if possible
that they would be able to access
criminal records
on their own from a secure terminal of
some type
um so we're going to put a pin in that
also
um
with regard to that I would propose that
we ask for a limited number of
amount of money to onboard these folks
when they come aboard
you know they they have to have I mean
and correct me if I'm wrong you need a
cell phone
you need some type of a laptop iPad
something
um but I mean what what type of
equipment do you I mean you're spending
a lot out of your own Pockets to do this
efficiently now and I don't mean Bare
Bones to do it efficiently when I
started back in 2016
and I had my own cell phone
they did provide me copies I'd go in and
I'd periodically get 10 or 15 but it's
sometimes inevitably when I needed
something they were busy so it got to a
point it was more convenient just to
make my own and just go from there over
time as we aged arthritis and whatnot
and I was taking a look at my
handwriting and since I was complaining
about Judges handwriting so we couldn't
read on the bail orders I figured it was
time to Pony up I got my iPad I got a
program that allowed me to go in and be
able to utilize the state forms as they
were
and sold with sure and then they started
putting them out on the website and we
were able to download them and work with
them and I type all of that so over time
just myself because I wanted to put
forward a more professional and more
importantly I didn't want the defendant
to be able to say that I couldn't read
what they wrote
and have that as a loophole
and just to be clear I'm not going to
propose that we vote an amount of money
I'm going this is for me to when I meet
with the Chief Justice to say
what do you think about
providing your contractors with
something to start them up it'd be it
some kind of a startup package
we talked about it you put it as a
bridge too far
you have to in my view you have to ask
for something that's reasonable
everybody has a cell phone
everybody has a computer I don't use a
computer I use the police facilities
copying Mr Leary does it himself I find
the police departments are very
Cooperative about letting me make my
copies there so I think that is
I want to keep any request that this
committee makes
uh reasonable and I think people may nod
their heads but they're not going to
believe that we have to provide cell
phones or something and that's just
operating equipment for everybody
but
the big thing that should be on that
list mother Heavens is it training
that's got to be I mean I I sorry
oh
remember we are independent contractors
we bring our own tools to the job and I
agree with representative scitec I think
that's definitely more than a bridge
it's like three or four or five bridges
too far
especially to equip that amount of
people
but I Echo hit what he said is training
and where the court was willing to go
out and hire one person to train 15
magistrates
I think or the moment the bill that was
put in is that hired that same person
and have them train the bail
Commissioners and that means new bail
Commissioners that come in they meet
with that person that is designed to do
the training set it up and give them the
basic training then they go out and
Shadow a bail commissioner actually
doing the work out in the field I think
would be you know miles ahead and again
looking to the Future so that other
people that would sit here before you
would be appropriately you know trained
and have the
respect so to speak of the office and
not be treated as an afterthought I
think those are the important things and
by the training alone I think it UPS the
professionalism of the group you're
fortunate that you have a huge
professional group but there's some too
like with every group that could need a
little bit more help in that area
so in in that
vein just so um represents scitec
doesn't have to bring it up again we all
agree that whatever we pass is going to
require and just as a side note
generally speaking we wouldn't tell
another branch of government what to do
with their employees but they're not
their employees so I I feel very
comfortable since they are serving both
the judicial executive
we we can as the legislature say what
they they need so everyone agrees
training should be part of onboarding
and at least annually or more often if
the laws are changed that require it is
that seem reasonable to everybody
go ahead represent
oh I was just going to say when it comes
to the laptops and stuff maybe this is
something we put off depending on how
you know the rest of this conversation
goes but maybe it could be more of a
reimbursement system instead of upfront
providing people with the technology
they need that way if people you know
don't have an iPad or a laptop that day
or if it breaks you know they're able to
get one
um I employ independent contractors and
I give them mileage reimbursement and
reimbursement for you know costs that
they spend to complete the job
I also was going to say that if we're
looking into allowing them to you know
access criminal records and stuff like
that then maybe it does have to be a
state issued laptop so I think that's
something we also need to think about I
think that that that issue I'm going to
address with the Chief Justice and
so
into the to the two bail Commissioners
uh president's point if I was going to
suggest that we fund
um some kind of a startup package they I
agree that
because it's such an ethereal thing you
know some people need it some people
don't
but if we talk to the Chief Justice to
say look
what do you think what what would be
appropriate in your mind even to your
point of reimbursement type of system
that we could put seed money into start
that they could fund out of their budget
when they ask for a new budget so
that'll just be part of the conversation
I have with the court I don't think it's
something we'll necessarily try to
mandate to legislation unless the court
agrees to it representative Stone thank
you
I guess what I'm looking at the training
aspect I think we should consider if
it's going to be maybe a mandated
four-hour block of training annually
because once they have the initial
training really it's more of a refresher
course for the change of law that should
probably be done at least annually yeah
we need to prescribe the time amount
that should be allocated to that or we
should leave that up to them I think we
leave that up to the courts they I think
that they know
they know at least as long as we mandate
we can use a descriptor substantial some
type of descriptor to say that this
training has to be actually not just you
know five minutes
I think we can massage that language out
without putting an hour limit to it
um represent I'm
go ahead no I'm not interested yeah
I would think that you might want to
Loop commissioner Quinn in from the
Department of Safety because he's the
one that signs off on the bottom line of
all of the stuff doing with the
NCIS the uh I'm already meeting with the
attorney general so he reports to him so
but the thing is he's the one who's got
to sign off on all of that stuff so he
probably could answer the questions a
lot easier and quicker for you or send
someone over that could so that you
could ask the questions that you needed
good call
okay so
um back to the stand on Focus we agree
on training did you have something I saw
you raise your hand for a second then
pull it back down when I took away the
hours you put it back down yeah okay so
we're going to mandate training but
we're not going to tell them how to do
it we're going to mandate that they have
initial training and that they have
annual training or as the Law changes go
ahead represent I don't know I don't
know whether it's RSA or Court rule but
we do have an annual training or an
annual refresher where we sit down and
that typically is an hour maybe more uh
it's we have a rather free-flowing
conversation uh with our district court
judge it's typically held in October and
many times I've sat there thinking
wouldn't it be nice if I were listening
to other courts how come is our own is
our wisdom confined only to this forum a
nice for that just
I think what we heard though is that
it's really um it's really
um depending on where you are what if
you get training what the training
contains we heard someone who went to
two different trainings within a week
and they were different um so I think we
needed it to be standardized across the
state and it needs to be
mandatory and so many to sign off that
it occurred
so I think that that we don't need to
get into the Weeds about what it
contains we just need to make sure that
it happens and somebody signs off that
it happened
representative Muse
it doesn't sound like there is any kind
of certification process for this so
it's one thing to provide training to
make training available and to even
require people to take the training
um the other the other big issue is how
much of the training actually sinks in
um you know and that has to do with the
comprehensiveness and the effectiveness
of of the training itself
so you know to me if there was if there
was one thing
that we might want to also think about
it would be some sort of basic
competency assessment or test that
somebody might take before they're just
sort of thrown out there in this
situation for the first time and that
would be my primary worry because you
know if you if you do the math if we
have 85 Bill Commissioners now
um sounds like we're down 35 from where
we were pre-covered so if if we do some
things that make it better and more
attractive for people to to be bail
Commissioners one of the things we could
be dealing with you know in a perfect
world might be an influx of new
applicants uh so how do you do that how
do you ensure that people you know who
are new to the job can deliver a service
that is reasonably consistent with what
more experienced people might deliver
and and I think that what I get a little
bit worried when I hear about uh four
hours of training and then somebody's
making bail decisions who's never done
it before and and uh and and I think
that's kind of been where we are and
we've sort of found a way ways to make
it work but again you know if we're
talking about
professionalizing this and uh I I think
one of the ways that people get
respected and they get treated like
professionals is that they have
consistent training and that there are
consistent standards across the board
that professionalize the occupation
so
um having some type of an assessment
would be a good idea I think I think too
yeah we could um we could and how that
looks in the language I'm gonna hold off
on until we speak to the courts but we
could require that they after their
initial training that they ex display
competency in the knowledge that they've
just received without making it um too
complicated or a big deal uh
representative Stone
thank you Mr chair isn't it my
understanding and correctly if I'm wrong
but these individuals are appointed by
district court judge for where you serve
or no it's done by AOC now
it it used to be by your local uh your
District Court Judge it's now done by
the administer uh by the administration
AOC judge of these uh of the Court
thank you it's done out of uh Granite
Street somewhere just follow up
since these positions are volunteer
positions uh and the courts obviously
have a understanding of the individual's
background I think that needs to be in
consideration when we're looking at
going too far to professionalize
something that they are volunteers these
are basically a kind of a per diem rate
that's relatively low and what you're
demanding them I think we have to really
balance that out and not
overdo it with regulation at the same
time
I agree but I I also representative Muse
that they should at least be able to
display a competency before they hit the
streets so to say and how what that
looks like I'll leave to the courts to
decide that way we're not going too too
far as far as
micromanaging a relationship between the
contractor and the subcontractor go
ahead represent Muse
and and I think one of the things we
shouldn't forget too is that although
these folks are volunteers the decisions
that they make
um impact the freedom of of individuals
in the justice system they're very very
important decisions
uh agreed and when we're talking about
the you know a decision about whether
someone stays or goes could have
implications into their job their family
life
a huge huge ramifications so um I I see
nothing wrong with making sure that the
initial appointees can display a level
of Competency and knowledge of the law
in what that looks like would leave to
the courts to decide so
representative Pratt
I was a commissioner of safety for fire
standard and training for income he is
we always wrestle with the idea of how
much training uh is beneficial how much
training stops the volunteers from
coming in and across the state in New
Hampshire we have some of the highest
training level hours of any other state
and because of that volunteerism is
dropping off because it's hovering
around 200 hours
to become a firefighter and so a lot of
firefighters just say I don't have 200
hours
how much
you ask of a person that's getting forty
dollars every other time they go out I I
agree and thank you that that that
knowledge is is valuable
um and the firefighters all likewise are
Vol these are volunteer firefighters and
they're not getting paid for that
training either are they yeah so we we
have to be cognizant of that to uh
mandating you know many hours of
training for someone who's not getting
paid is
is indeed almost a punishment so again I
go back to let's leave the court what
they think
much training they need we just want to
mandate that they have it that it's
uniform and that before they take the
the role they have a basic understanding
of the role representative side Tech uh
representative Muse stole by the Thunder
that no matter what the training is or
however they are making real decisions
concerning people's Liberty yes you
can't underestimate that agreed where I
it's there has to be it's part of this
training
the laboratory what I'm calling the
laboratory like a field training officer
you go out and you actually see this
being done there's just something about
getting your hands into the dirt and
seeing this the process at work
it's more than ethereal it's it you're
dealing with real people in a real
situation just to feel you get for that
and you can't get in a classroom it's
got to be part of any training is that
agreed and we can take
um police field training officers they
have to do
um tandem most departments now you don't
just hit the street
um and I think the same should go that
there should be a period of shadowing
um however again back to its volunteer
and there unless that uh you're going to
split your forty dollars with your uh
with your ride-along partner but we can
um again I really hesitate to
micromanage with the court how they do
it so we can make strong suggestions
um Professor share
ah
I wasn't committed not saying anything
today but as a law professor I just
can't resist
uh two points um
I think this committee has got to decide
whether they're going to treat bail
Commissioners like volunteers
or like paid
contractors you know if somebody's
getting 50 bucks and 50 bucks for uh
being a bail commissioner in a
particular case they're no longer
volunteers so I just caution the
committee
between treating you know using the term
volunteer and also being aggressive
which I completely agree with about
these people getting paid the money
they're due but if they're getting paid
that money they're not don't use the
word volunteers it it'll just confuse
the conversation with the court system I
just have language thing
um second you know
in thinking about training and thinking
about
the shall we call it
decentralized organization of bail
Commissioners in the state you know one
of the recommendations that might be
worth talking to the court about and
being in legislation is to fund a
part-time position in the court system
for managing bail commissioners
um
I think that
is the best model for pulling together
all the different stuff the all the
different and good stuff that everyone's
been talking about today and yesterday I
think I think and and I think uh
uh you know when the conversation occurs
with the court about bail Commissioners
you know they're going to say money
money money money you know who's going
to do yeah oh oh now we're going to add
some more uh uh tasks to people who
already have too many jobs
um and I think that's a legitimate
concern on the course part but you know
I think if if you bring this together
and think about giving the court a
part-time I think it's only needed for
part-time a part-time position
uh
bail commissioner coordinator let's call
it I think that is a model that the
court might well be very receptive to
and uh not make this a
conversation where
uh one party is saying you know you
courts you're falling down on your task
as to bail Commissioners and the courts
saying I I we don't have the money to do
all the things you want us to do I think
that could be a a a quickly spiral into
a negative conversation but if you you
know if you talk about you know we
really want to improve Bill
Commissioners here's our thought what do
you think of this that might be a better
approach and I think that that was the
approach I intended to take but I really
I like that idea
um that there does need to be somebody
who is um who's has eyes on on this
whole thing because it is balkanized and
um
from one District to the next I mean
it's hard for I want to be able to call
a court and see how many Bill
Commissioners are there and someone to
say this many as of today and how many
Bales were done last year this many as
of right now that should be in to your
point I think a coordinator who can look
up and maintain and the way I would put
it you know and talking to people in
business
um
when they assign projects to people in
their business what they were looking
for a phrase I've heard repeatedly is I
want somebody who wakes up in the
morning thinking about bail
Commissioners yeah and we don't have
that and that would be really helpful
thank you Professor does the does the
committee agree with that idea that we
should propose to the courts and if they
agree
um try to fund a part-time position to
be the bail commissioner coordinator
whatever they want to call it's their
their job representative Newman
but I I intended to listen more than
talk
did some training
in the FAA and you have people that
train and check
controllers and pilots and stuff like
that
and I think that the really important
part of that is if you do have one
individual like you're going to talk
about that they go and they do check
rides on on
kind of like check rides on on bail
Commissioners and then you would have
somebody that not only knew what was
going on with the bail Commissioners
they would also have an understanding of
what was going on with the various
courts and how
consistent the training is across the
whole training program I'll bring that
up in my conversation with the court
representative thank you Mr chairman I
think one of the things we have to be
very careful is one
is the system broken
or does the system need to be
kind of patch back together I think it's
a little bit of both and what we're
hearing is training training training
and the professor does bring up a good
point the more we go down this path of
creating a position in the court
creating a revenue source to make sure
they get paid we are now we are now
opening up another branch of employees
and that's going to be a very very
slippery slope so if we do create
something in the court system that says
all these people are going to be in
charge of the bill commissioners
we don't have anything like that to
start so who who Who's going to save
what this job is going to be who's going
to be the one to actually create the job
on the court system as a human resources
department and I believe that they would
probably have to write a job description
and then they would have to send it out
to get a salary analysis there's a whole
huge process we that's why we we stay
away from the micromanagement I'm going
to suggest this and I said I would I
would Hazard a guess that the court
system as long as we're willing to pay
for it would be happy to have it
um so let's let's see what they say
representative Reed thank you Mr
chairman how about it would that fall
under somebody's job description that's
already working in the court system
because it doesn't sound like a very
time consuming thing to keep track of
that data it's my understanding that the
the courts right now
are understaffed and um and I don't
believe that that's any form of an
exaggeration and based on our visit
there as you can see they it's it's a
very busy busy business and they they
are not at their Staffing levels as it
is so if we were to tell them find some
time for someone
they're going to say sure but it's going
to take away from this and it's just
going to representative Pratt it's still
a possibility that we're looking at uh
making the courts work six days a week
because that's a very expensive one we
talked about before
um it's a very real possibility that
we're going to discuss um having at
least one judge on the weekends to
handle these and we already know there's
one doing emergency orders so we're
going to have that conversation and I I
think for that for any of this and I
don't want to get too far down this road
because it's going to be another day but
yeah
if we're going to mandate a list of
crimes that cannot be bailed by a bail
commissioner then we cannot do that
without having somebody alternatively be
able to hear within 24 hours
a judge to be able to hear it so I think
the two things are inextricably linked
and as we know our friends in the Senate
have kind of drawn that line and we won
at least these crimes so I suggest that
we say okay you can have the crimes but
you have to be able to have somebody
there to hear these people so they at
least have an opportunity to get out
because again go back to Presumed
Innocent one more follow ahead yeah sure
um maybe that would be the person that
would be able to see in the bail
commissions or that
possible night court or whatever it is
yeah possibly but I'll we'll discuss
that like I said they they have a they
have a human resources department they
they they're going to want to put their
their
um their own process in place to try and
figure out their time management I'm
just willing to say are we willing to
are we willing to fund a part-time
position and let them figure out how to
how to deal with it so
um I just want to be able when I go to
the core station the subcommittee thinks
that we would be able to vote to support
such a thing if you are open to it
representative Stone thank you
so it's my understanding that they don't
have someone currently that oversees any
of the bail operations or Commissioners
or someone who is at least charged with
that responsibility within AOC
I think probably very Loosely um
Professor share
the responsibility
for
the primary responsibility for bail
Commissioners is with the administrative
judge for the district court system
um
that judge has a tremendous amount of
responsibilities on their plate
and uh to representative Reed's
discussion you know the very problem
with bail Commissioners in part has been
there's nobody who wakes up in the
morning thinking about bail
commissioners it's probably not a
full-time job but to organize consistent
repeated training to develop a shadowing
program to recruit bail Commissioners
you know I I think that's a substantial
job and you know I've known the last
three consecutive
administrative judges and boy
they just don't have the time
to do this in the way it needs to be
done for uh what else is on their plate
that that judge just give us the gives
the committee a feeling for what else
that administrative judge has to oversee
they've got 32 or 33 Circuit Court
judges
who on a daily basis create messes
and run into problems you know they're
it to be uh
I have tenure into law school so I can
say this but they
you know they're like
uh 33 teenage cats that the
administrative judge is hurting
um they're just they do stuff that that
they can't do they need to be told to
back off they have to manage uh the
administrative judge has to manage the
relationships between those judges and
the Clerks of Court
and negotiate those relationships with
the administrative office of the Court
which is in charge of the Clerks of
Court
they need to right now they need to
unwind the felonies first program and
get ready to have probable cause
hearings once again held in District
Court which is a a huge administrative
burden
um uh and that's just you know
and they have to do the the budget work
uh this is a
it's important to bail Commissioners
it's important to the system but bail
Commissioners as a relative matter or
a blip on their radar in terms of having
time to focus on it
so to your point they're not waking up
in the morning thinking about bail
Commissioners unless something bad
happened overnight something really bad
you know I don't I'm not sure they ever
wake up any morning during the year
thinking about bail Commissioners
um
thank you for that um and I I think
there should be somebody at the court
who does wake up and and a good point
was just raised recruiting Bill
Commissioners so I'm keeping track of
how many when they're leaving right now
it sounds like nobody is and so you
could have a wave disappear and no one
would even know it until the police
started calling saying no one's
answering our calls to bail people so um
that's a that's a very important topic
to bring up with the court and I think
that with the support of the committee
we can discuss
funding and we will discuss that as well
with Finance
okay so we have training we have 50
funding
um we have the possibility of funding a
position to oversee and manage the bail
commissioner system
anything else what else am I missing I'm
sure I'm missing something
representative
paid we're not going to dabble in
mileage because we're going to up the
rate
yeah indeed there is I don't think we
need to add any more we talked about
swearing swearing in right yep we're
going to look into that we're gonna
we've got the ID we agree on
training consistency I think we're those
are all my friends
okay
so I think we can wrap up that portion
of
this discussion a lot of it is
contingent upon
the reception we received from the
courts
I'm willing to mandate the courts do
things to a certain limit but only to
the Limit that they can do them and we
don't know that until we talk to them
representative did you
yeah one of the one of the things we may
want to do because I know our a lot of
our conversations have been pretty
pretty wide-ranging
um and uh
one thing I'm I'm a little bit concerned
about is if we
if we're
if we're too ambitious with whatever
legislation that we decide to put
forward
uh
you know will we be able to get it
passed will the folks in the other body
agree to it
um so I mean one of the things one of
the things to think think about doing
too is to
um and maybe we can
you know we can kind of think about this
but at some point when we're done with
this have some sort of uh prioritization
around what what really needs you know
what what's essential to have going
forward and and then I think it's it's
fine to say and we and we also recommend
you know action on these things and some
of these things
the court May well may be able to do
administratively
um especially if we connect them to
systemic issues that are causing
problems in other areas because a lot of
these things that we've identified just
sort of tend to metastasize in other
places
I'm a little hesitant on that because we
do have a statute that the bail
Commissioners received training and that
doesn't seem to have seemed to have
taken quite so I think we do need to we
need to Define that but my intention was
we have I believe four or five bills
that we've retained and I think that
what we do is we prioritize and we we
compartmentalize this into those
different bills so that you know we've
got our main belt that has the things
that just have to be fixed and then we
have the things that you know we still
think are really important but if they
get pushed to the Wayside the system
still goes on and survives and it's
we've fixed at least
the minimum of what we could but I feel
like at this this point in history this
body has dealt with this so many times
that it's now time to take a real
um a real bite at just fixing it and
stop trying to whittle around the edges
because it'll just be back in you and
I'll be here again next next year
hopefully and doing it again and so
let's just move on if we can and
hopefully get this all
in a in a global fix
and I'm aware of the danger of being too
ambitious I have spoken to our
counterparts some of them on the uh in
the other chamber in their concern Still
Remains these list of crimes so I feel
like as long as we get that in there
everything else should be okay as long
as we can come up with the money so
let's shoot high aim for the stars and
see where we end up I don't think
anyone's willing to let the thing just
go away based on you know that so again
we still have hurdles we still have to
get the courts to agree so barring that
you know the legislation might shrink
represent Pratt uh we talked the other
day about bail and I know it used to be
uh for a more serious crime you actually
uh paid more money for the bail and it
sounded like that went away
I don't understand how all that is yeah
um
so it's my understanding that because I
wasn't part of that in 2018.
a large contingent of the people who are
who are arrested and make up the
majority of this have no money they just
don't so you know you could set
a thousand dollar bill you could set a
hundred dollar bill they're not going to
have it so what happens is they end up
being staying incarcerated just based on
the mere fact that they're poor and
that's not what the justice system was
designed to do bail cash Bill still
exists and can be used
um in egregious cases and where someone
actually has money so if you have a
corporation somebody uh you know gets
involved in a big white collar crime
thing you can set a million dollars bail
and that that would hurt them to lose it
so that would ensure that they come but
if you set a bail of a thousand dollars
to a homeless person you've just been
caution you might as well just said hold
them well just to play Devil's attitude
on that oh absolutely a person that has
nothing is more likely probably to flee
the state if they were looking at time
I agree and that's still that's still
available to hold flight risks they just
have to show why they would be a Flight
Risk
um and someone without a car can't fly
too far right
um that's that's that's actually one of
the things we're going to discuss next
week is the second part we've talked
about the dangerousness we're going to
touch on Flight Risk because those are
the two key aspects of why we have bail
one are they a danger the public if they
let out two are they a risk of flight
and we haven't even talked about flight
so that we're going to talk about that
next week
anyone else have anything
let's see what I'm just we're going to
take uh we're gonna take 15 minutes
and we're going to come back and if
there's anything else we can touch on
today we will if not we'll wrap up
calling the meeting back to order
um
so um
we we've talked about a great bit today
I think we've made some good progress as
far as our as far as our structure of
what we're going to discuss with the
courts
um I've just been informed that it's
likely that we'll have a meeting with
the Chief Justice sometime the first
week of October myself and represent
gather right and um
probably represent Rhodes and another
representative that representative
gathright chooses representative Muse is
going to be gone unfortunately but we'll
sort out the logistics of that but it
looks like it's going to be the first
week in October
um one thing I want to address for us to
think about
um this is back to homework again if if
you've looked online like we were
talking about yesterday to see all these
forms they have to put out
um the bill commissioner where he went
he gave me a copy of all of them that
I'm going to ask to be copied and put in
everybody's box next week so you'll have
it when you come back one thing I wanted
to address though before we leave for
the day and I'd like everyone to think
about over the next week
is that we've talked a lot about these
crimes and we've talked about you know
the Felon and and the seriousness of
these crimes but what we haven't
addressed I think and and we need to at
least think about the majority of the
problems for example the city of
Manchester and Nashua are having
aren't these crimes they're nuisance
type crimes they're picking up people
for trespass for a disorderly person
um and and they're bailing them out on
personal cognizance and they're picking
them up a few hours later the next day
and it's happening you know three and
four times sometimes over a weekend with
the same person I'd like everyone on the
committee to think about you know how
how we could tackle that issue keeping
in mind the the principle that we don't
want to hold people because they're poor
or mentally ill
but also taking that that burden off the
local communities of same people
committing the same nuisance crime over
and over over a short period of time
um perhaps look at it through the lens
of okay you get picked up the second
time that weekend perhaps we need to
look at directing
not necessarily be held in jail but
maybe an evaluation to see what's going
on with them
something's happening be it mental
health be it substance
let's look at how we can direct those
people to get the services they need
rather than just put them into jail for
the weekend
um
that way we're helping both the
community and the individual who's
having these obvious issues that they
have to keep you getting picked up any
thoughts on that representative
you know from from a homework
perspective one of the things that's
always interesting as a legislator is
typically for almost any issue that you
want to consider at some point or
another there's been a commission or a
committee that's been appointed to study
the issue so back in 2022 the governor
appointed an advisory Commission on
mental illness in the corrections system
and their full report and
recommendations are available and I have
those and they address a lot of the
things that I think we've heard
consistently about in testimony some of
the systemic issues so it's it's a
homeless person who might be arrested
for shoplifting at Market Basket who is
out on PR bail and then an hour later
the same officer is rearresting them
again at Market Basket for shoplifting
so there are people
who commit small offenses over and over
and over again um and
there are substantial number of people
like that in in our County jails so the
issue is is how do we sort of get out of
this cycle where the criminal justice
system for better or worse seems to be
warehousing people who have deeper
problems
um so this commission has actually uh
dealt into kind of dove into that a bit
they do have recommendations so what
I'll do is I'll send their final report
to uh the members of the committee
agreed that that is a very excellent
idea so take a look at that and then put
your own thoughts towards what you see
in that report and what you think about
the issue I encourage also the members
of the the subcommittee to um to reach
out to your local police Chiefs and get
their input and what what they're
dealing with on a local basis
um daily and maybe even take a trip to
your local circuit court and just have a
have a look at what's going on there
talk to some people come back to the
committee with what you find and we'd
like to incorporate as much of that as
we can I mean we've heard from the folks
here that come here but while we're here
talking about it real life's going on
out there and we want to find out what
our local local people are going through
too so take a look at the report Dave's
going to circulate
put a thought to how these these for
lack of a better term nuisance crimes
that are really what are causing this
consternation with the with the citizens
in the in the police with the the repeat
offenders it's it's generally not the
you know the the first degree assaults
and the attempted murders it's the
shoplifting it's the trespass it's the
disorderly person
and you know we we need to look at a way
to break the cycle of just putting them
in jail until they get back out again do
the same thing we need to look at
focusing towards okay we're going to get
him off the street but we're not just
gonna
to use David's term Warehouse them we're
going to see if we can look at where
they need to get these services and
connect them with these services and if
after having had these Services they
continue then it becomes a criminal
issue but until then let's see if it's
not first in mental health or substance
issue that we can actually address with
resources that are out there even if
it's just connecting them with a private
agency that provides these services in
the community so that's really all I
would ask of you over the next week
until we meet again
have a care to that visit your Chiefs if
you have time and see what's going on in
your local communities anyone without
any have anything else before we close
for the day
seeing none closing the public hearing
until next Thursday
foreign
good afternoon everybody it is one
o'clock
I am going to open up our subcommittee I
think this is a hearing I'm not exactly
sure what to call it work session
um for our two retained bills the first
one we are going to hear is
uh House Bill 593 FN and we are going to
invite representative McGuire to just
say a few words
before we make any decisions
thank you madam chair members of the
committee for the record my name is Dan
McGuire I represent the town of Epsom so
I'm the prime sponsor of this bill and
I'm here to request that you find it uh
in interim study so if you're not
familiar with that interim study is
emotion applicable to second year bills
and because this was retained it's now a
second year bill and it's also known as
death With Dignity so it it has the
effect of somewhat of the effect of itl
the bill would not become law but on the
other hand the subject matter would
still be open in the sense that if a
bill came from the senate for example or
some other bill in the house
was somehow related it could still be be
discussed so there's actually been over
the summer a fair amount of work going
on with this bill you may recall that we
had some difficulty with the Judiciary
well we've had many meetings with the
Judiciary we have new language that
they're happy with Etc and so I could
have come to you today with like another
15-page amendment or something like that
but I decided not to do that
and um I'll I'll see if if I can work
through the process and get that in as
another bill some in you know in another
way and that's my plan and if not I'll
wait on another year but but rather than
you know try to rework and rework this
bill please uh just find it interim
study thank you
representative my question
yeah I have just a question because I
mean you told the process of an interim
study
um so what what is it in the house rules
that that prevents you from just
submitting it as a different bill
yeah thanks for your question house rule
36e says that if a bill is retained or
found itl in the first year right it
cannot be reintroduced so in order to
reintroduce this and my plan is I'm
actually going to be breaking it up into
three different bills so it's a little
more manageable but I have to go to the
rules committee so I I'm on the agenda
for the rules committee on October 10th
to talk about this thank you for the
explanation
does anybody else have any questions for
representative McGuire
okay so before we take this um this vote
I just would like to say real quick that
I cannot take credit for the work that
is in front of me um this was given to
me by somebody who works a lot harder
than I do
and I do have the history of forfeiture
bills over the last couple of years uh
some of them
have actually been signed into law but
will not be going into effect
um or actually just went into effect a
lot of them are either getting killed on
the house floor or they're not making it
quite through the Senate
and this is I have this here I'm happy
to share this with anybody wants to take
a look at it
um in addition to that I also made a
couple of phone calls about this
legislation and I did talk with
representative McGuire as well
and you know when we looked through this
and we met the first time
and most of you would remember we did
have representative Lynn here and we
talked about
this being so broad does it all belong
in criminal justice and that was one of
the biggest problems that we had so
basically where we are now is
it is my understanding and with the
conversations I've had with
representative that it's going to be
broken up into different sections at the
at the leadership level and this will
not all be coming to Criminal Justice at
least not the first time around some of
it may be going to Transportation some
of it may be gone to Judiciary it's not
for me to decide where it goes I just
know that it doesn't all necessarily
belong in this committee we're not you
know the the subject matters to be
discussed on those things so
with that being said who wants to make a
motion
what was your emotion
fantastic do we have a second
in by representative Reed
um
I don't have a list here to know who's
first to to vote does it really matter
no
okay
representative are you on the
subcommittee you're not
okay Bradley's not here
okay all right we'll start with
representative
um radio yes
representative Newman votes yes
please
Chairman's yes
two three four five yes zero no motion
passes
all right with that we will close the
work session for House Bill five
what is it
yeah what is this bill number help me
out here
we are closing the work session for
House Bill 593 event
do we actually have to wait until 1 30
to open the next one oh my God
so they both weren't just scheduled at
one o'clock
do you want me to deliver it to somebody
foreign
ladies and gentlemen it is
um 1 30 and the cafeteria only has one
person working and we do have a member
that is just
um coming back back upstairs so we are
going to open this and just go into a
recess for just a few minutes and so
he's able to join us so please bear with
us a couple minutes
okay ladies and gentlemen we are now
going to reopen the work session for
House Bill 113 and uh representative
Abbott is here who is the main sponsor
representative Jew want to talk to us
yes the only thing I I don't have
anything really to add to the testimony
I have presented at the public hearing
the the only thing I think that uh that
this building does
um is it does eliminate the state
requirements for physical
exams it does not limit any
local agency from having physical
requirements and I think what the
situation we find ourselves in today
not only on the state level but on the
national level is the difficulty in
recruiting and retaining police officers
and I think that this
is should be something that's under
local control and not mandated by the
state we are the only state that
mandates physical requirements for
police officers and we also
um
makes it difficulty a very difficult for
communities like I represent
which are small towns and recruiting and
retaining police officers so this is why
I put the bill in and I just
that's all I have thank you
thank you representative
so um
I'm going to go ahead and say a few
things one is
I have had extensive
conversations
um with director skippa and
we actually we actually talked about
many many different options and one of
the things that was discussed was the
fact of this being in local control
and one of the concerns that I had and
after I think about 45 minutes of you
know he and I having just a conversation
one of the things that I that I was
concerned about with that
was
some towns using this
in a negative way so in other words if
they had an officer that for whatever
reason they wanted to get rid of and
it's unfortunate that I do know of some
examples that I could give but I
certainly will not do that
that could have been changed they could
have said oh we are you know we're not
going to require it anymore because you
know we're having trouble recruiting or
retaining or whatever the reason will be
and then all of a sudden nope we're
gonna you know we have so and so that we
think is going to have difficulties and
we're going to switch it and I I was
really nervous about a pendulum I didn't
want it just going back and forth and
being able to change at the will of a
police off the police off I'm sorry a
police chief or the town selectman
um and we did come up with a solution to
that however that solution just you know
we just kept on going down this Rabbit
Hole of every time we turned around
there was another obstacle that just
wasn't going to be solved with what we
were trying to solve
so I have a lot more to add but that is
at least what I want to say about the
local control thing
um and I did ask Brad he's done a lot of
work for all of us and I did ask him if
he would please pull up what other
states around us do in New England
um I also had him look at what is
required to become a police officer in
the state of New Hampshire versus other
states around us and I actually had him
go even a little bit deeper than that
and pull up what are the standards for
the military
and federal positions and one of the
things I know for a fact my husband is a
railroad engineer I should say he's a
railroad locomotive engineer
and he is required every year to have a
physical he has to have a hearing test
he has a sleep apnea test many many that
he has to do that is a requirement of
his job along with random drug testing
at will
um used to be every year I do believe
they went back to the federal standard
which is every three years
um and I do know that Pilots also have
requirements that they have to do and
they also have a mandatory retirement
age that I will add right
um so I don't know I think Brad sent
this to everybody if you didn't get it I
do have a copy and you're all welcome to
look at it
um so that's all I'm going to say about
that for now is there anybody else that
wishes that has anything to say
representative wheeler
I do think that having standards for our
police officers physical standards is is
quite important and as was talked about
at lunch between representative Muse and
myself and representative Newman and
Murphy
New Hampshire has actually been
congratulated and given as an example in
other states for our physical fitness
requirements and I would say that
getting rid of them would put the Public
Safety in Jeopardy if we have people who
can't do the job of a police officer
being able to catch a perp if they're
running away or any of the very physical
tasks that are needed when you're a
police officer then that puts our
communities at risk it just opens up the
door for criminals to be able to know
well this town's got some cops that are
down and dirty and we can we can do
whatever we want here and I think it's
important that we have physical fitness
requirements so that our cops are doing
the job right and well and that they're
fit and able to do it and I have seen
that in our police officers here in New
Hampshire and think it's important to to
maintain this so whenever you're ready
I'd be happy to make make a motion
thank you representative wheeler hold on
a minute I think we have some people to
have something to say this is being
recorded you do know that
[Laughter]
is that me
I'm up okay
um
I'm for repealing this bill and I'll
tell you why I understand the concern
about standards and being able to catch
a perp however if you look at these
standards
a 59 year old police officer has to do
the mile and a half run I think it's
five seconds
slower than an 18 year old female
so when we start differentiating
genders and ages
and there are different standards for
each one
how does that how does that make uh
someone able to catch a perp or be able
to do the job better if they don't have
to run as fast when they get older or if
they're a different gender
in addition we're losing experienced
officers
usually those guys that have 25 years 30
years on their police Chiefs their
captains they're not out there chasing
people but they have 30 years experience
and we're going to lose that because
they can't pass a Physical Agility Test
you're not paid to do this to train
you're not paid to keep in shape and if
you get hurt while you're out there
training for your test guess what you're
out of a job
because workman's comp is not going to
cover you
New Hampshire is the only state that
requires this every three years
in addition we don't require our
firefighters to do it or our EMS people
to do it just saw police officers
I don't think this should be tied to
someone's certification I know that most
towns have a Physical Agility
requirement that's incentive based if
you want to take it I know in the towns
that I've worked in and just with some
background I've worked in law
enforcement for 30 years however I'm not
a chief
um
but
they will pay you to pass it every three
years and a lot of guys take that and
take that Advantage it's extra money
they'll keep in shape and I know a lot
of guys will still keep in shape just
for that incentive base that each Town
provides I don't think tying it to your
certification and if you miss a push-up
by one or you miss the Run by 10 seconds
you're out of a job
this law went into effect I think it was
2001 I might be wrong on the date but um
prior to that we did fine
for however long police officers existed
before 2001
we had no issues with them being in
shape we had no issues with them getting
her extra or catching perps we operated
be prior to that so
I think it's about time we repeal this
the standard will stay in place for
recruitment when you first get hired to
get in the academy and to get out of the
academy but after that tying it to your
certification I don't I don't think is
the way we should be doing it that's it
thank you
representative Murray Murphy I'm sorry
close enough thank you
um
I I
agree with some of Representative
Stone's point the difference I have an
opinion is around whether it's
appropriate to make this decision
legislatively or to have police
standards in training
reassess their current requirements um
and I feel like that's the appropriate
place for this fully recognizing that
any of us as we get older are not going
to be as physically fit maybe as as
maybe with some mere exceptions
um as we were when we were 18 or 19 but
if I remember correctly some of the
testimony that we had about concern was
about liability too
um whether a partner wasn't necessarily
is in good physical shape whether there
would be liability because potential
liability for departments if a police
officer an incident involving
um
a a police officer that wasn't as
physically fit and that it impacted
um
the public
I I support a change if that's deemed
appropriate but I think that the members
should be the people
doing this with the department and I
would um fully recognizing we are having
you know Staffing challenges within the
PD I think we're seeing that across the
board in many positions
um uh I know that right now we only
require this every three years and we
heard from some officers who had been
given
um there was some kind of of plan in
place for them to have more time to to
come into compliance so I think there
are exceptions I think there are
um there are ways to to
um you know before an officer is no
longer certified there are things in
place
um and I I feel that the place for this
to happen is actually with police
standards and training and not for us to
legislatively
decide that we we would not have uh
um that this you know to remove this
from from RSA
thank you representative representative
um
representative Muse
and to representative Murphy's point we
we did have a really good robust
discussion during the uh the hearing
process and and the executive session
around possible alternatives
so I think one of the things we learned
from police standards in training is
that the way that they currently do it
that particular methodology is a couple
of decades old and they're they're
looking at changing it one of the things
that I suggested
um as a way of
losing some of those good officers who
basically can't meet the physical
standards anymore was creating uh some
type of an alternative a wellness
program for example that they could
participate in and potentially not uh
you know and and potentially not loser
certification
um but you know we when we start to get
into things like that what we start to
get into is sort of what I think we
should avoid which is the legislature
um micromanaging you know the the
agencies and and I do think that there
are people in police standards in
training who are underwear you know
they're aware of the fact that the
legislature has told them that we have
to have these standards but to a large
extent I mean we've left it up to them
to decide what the standard should be
so if the standards aren't working if
we're losing people because of it I
think that's a wake-up call for police
standards in training to really take a
good look at those standards
um but I don't necessarily think it's a
wake-up call for the legislature to get
rid of them especially
not one even even the police themselves
who testified so I it was it's always
unusual for the for the Chiefs of Police
Association to come and testify on a
bill and be neutral about it and the
reason they were neutral about it is
well there was some disagreement even
among among the Chiefs about whether or
not repeal was a good idea
so you know what what I would say is it
it might be a better idea to see what
police standards in training can do uh
to to continue to be in contact with
them
um but um in terms of repealing the
existing law I I think we should give it
a little bit more time to play out and
time for those discussions to play out
thank you representative representative
finzar
thank you uh I'm not recommending this
at all but if you really want to measure
physical fitness it should be tested
every six months I mean three years just
seems arbitrary and you could get out of
shape for two and a half years and
really bust your butt to get in shape so
these quote unquote fat cop you could be
a fat cop for two and a half years get
in shape past the test and be a fat cop
again that's all I'd like to add foreign
representative wheeler
well I just wanted to say I appreciate
uh what my friend representative Manion
talked about uh in his opposition to
this what I would say is I agree that
there is a problem with retention and
staffing issues within the police
within the industry of police but I I
don't know if the data Bears out that it
is the standards that is causing there
to be a lack of uh Staffing shortages I
think those Staffing shortages come more
from a lack of adequate pay in a world
where the cost of living has increased
so greatly over these last four six
years and I
um would say that us as a state living
up to Our obligation and trying to
adequately pay people more and looking
into other things I'd be happy to look
into how we could retain uh employees
state employees including our police
officers in a
more Humane and just way paying them
adequately but I don't know if getting
rid of the standards that has made New
Hampshire police officers solid and
secure over these last uh
22 years since 2001
um
is the way to get that done um I think
that lowers the standard uh lowers the
bar of where our police officers are at
which may yes in turn get us more people
in that job but that lowers the standard
uh and I think that it's important
especially for people who are enforcing
Justice on the streets to have a high
standard for those um and I think New
Hampshire should be proud that we have
that high standard right now I would
agree with representative tenzar that I
think the three-year number is a an
arbitrary one that is trying to play
Both Sides um but I would also agree
with representative Muse that that
should be up to police standards and
training and and we shouldn't be
micromanaging it here I think this just
opens up a can of worms for peeling this
that it wouldn't be beneficial for the
legislature to engage in and I think
that I apologize for jumping the gun
with my motion earlier I just really
wanted to get out of here but I but I I
do but I I really appreciate this debate
as well um so I would just say like yes
if we want if we want to work on
retention I'd be happy to work on
retention uh with you but I don't think
that uh
lowering the standard
for our police officers and and the
physical physical fitness requirements
they have uh is the way to do that
thank you representative sure
thank you madam chair I just want to go
on the record saying that this doesn't
affect me either way
um whether it passes or it's repealed
just so it doesn't affect my position so
I just want to go on the record and say
that thank you representative Muse
you're well set thanks
okay so one of the things that I would
like to point out that I think is very
important for everybody to understand is
that the police standards and Training
Academy does have the ability to to
change some of these rules and I also
know that they are allowed to make
reasonable accommodations also for for
officers
um
I do know that you know it has right
here in what I have it says any officer
who's unable to obtain the medical
clearance shall have shall have his or
her certification placed in
probationary status for a period of six
months which I'll be extended by the
Council of good causes is defined and
then it continues to go on
um so I do know that you know in the
event that the officer is not able to
for whatever reason you know pass that
test at that time they do have the
they they are able to go back and try
again and if I'm not mistaken I think
that's like a couple of years like it
doesn't just stop and I could be wrong
but I don't see anybody shaking their
head at me so I think I might be okay
um and the other thing that I think
everybody here has kind of mentioned but
I know representative Muse definitely
did
is that
this was a really healthy conversation
we had in here and it also was
incredibly healthy when the officers
themselves are all here testifying and
the problem that I'm having
is that
every single person I talk to for
everything every two people I talk to
they're split
they are split nobody seems to be able
to just have the solution to the problem
even if there is a problem and
additionally I do know that the the the
um the Chiefs Association did send out a
survey and that came back split and they
had a very low return rate so you know
they're not even able to make a decision
so without them being able to make a
decision I don't really see that it's
our position to make it for them I think
that that may be insulting
um so with that being said does anybody
else have anything to say
I just had this one yes you may thank
you
um I understand that the decision was
made in 2001 by the legislature to make
this a law
so we did get involved in it we didn't
make the decision to have it every three
years so
maybe they screwed up
representative wheeler
I'm sure I'd like to make a motion to
itl HB 113 or recommend an IPL motion of
113 to the full committee representative
wheeler has made a motion of itl is
there a second second
all right we have a second
um representative wheeler would you like
to
call a role want to just go around sure
um representative Murphy
yes
representative wheeler votes yes
Representative tensar no
representative Manion no representative
Muse
yes
chair Rhodes chair Rhodes yes
okay
that is one two three four four to two
so the motion to itl has passed four to
two
um and with that we will close the work
session for House Bill one three
thank you everybody
once again nice discussion
I know I really took it's like